okay so this next question is in your
books there are several religious
systems such as the seven the drowned
God the faceless man the old gods etc
how do you come up with such a detailed
yet entirely yet entirely distinct
doctrines are there any that aren't
detailed in the books um well yes to
start with the last part first yes there
are many religions that are not detailed
you can see some of them in in arges
Braavos chapters where she visits
passing through the islands of gods and
I throw in you know I throw in
references to 17 different obscure
religions that I'm probably never going
to reveal in in much detail but some of
them are of course you know little tips
of the hats to other other fantasy
authors and mythos is that I admire I
mean if there there is there is both a
Roger Zelazny tibideaux homage and I and
a HP Lovecraft homage and on that Isle
of the Gods for those who are sharp
enough to us to see them I do that kind
of [ __ ] all the time so the three
stooges are in book 1 if you're sharp
enough to find them the major religions
that actually play a significant role in
the story are somewhat based on real
religions or real religious systems
although I don't I don't believe in just
doing you know a one to one
transformation where I'm gonna take like
Islam and file off the serial numbers
and comb Islam or something and
pretend it's the same you know I take
certain tenets of the religions but then
I maybe take part of this and part of
that and I meld them together and I
think about it and I had a few
imaginative elements but you know
certainly the old guards of the north
with the the trees worship I mean that's
based on animism and then traditional
pagan beliefs of Wicca and you know
various other Celtic systems and Norse
systems melded into a construct of my
own and and with the fantasy element of
the weirwood trees added as a as a
central element there the the faith of
the seven is you know very loosely
modeled on the medieval Catholic Church
but again with different elements I mean
course the Catholic Church which I was
I'm no longer a practicing Catholic but
that was how I was born and raised you
know has the whole concept that heart of
a Trinity which was you know explained
to me as well it's three but it's also
one you know which kids can never get
it's like okay we have three gods no no
you're not a three God one God
he has three you know parts okay so we
don't have three we just have one right
it's like the Shamrock that was hell you
know the three leaf clover so I I did
that except I made it seven instead of
three I have two holes well we have
seven gods we have seven personas
instead of Father Son Holy Ghost we have
maiden mother Crone which of course I
took from paganism as the traditional
female thing I kind of hobbled the male
side together and then I added the
stranger as the as the god of death
who's also the center of the the cult of
the faceless man I mean I think worship
of death is is an interesting basis for
religion because after all death is the
one universal it doesn't even no matter
what gods you pray to we all done like
in the real world and in fantasy worlds
and if there was one culture we did not
though I suspect that would be that God
would become very popular
and they will promise us eternal life
but whatever so my my faith with its
hierarchies it's high septon and it's
EPS and it's orders of you know
essentially monks and and priests and so
forth is is loosely based on Catholicism
and then you have the the red God the
Lord of Light from across the sea which
has a certain so or asterism elements to
it with the the fire worship and so
forth and and the duality and also a lot
from the emergency and heresy the
Cathars who were exterminated by the
Catholics and the great alba jinseyun
crusade but they had the fundamental
belief a dualist religion that there
were two gods there was a good God an
evil God and the world we live in was
created by the evil God which you know
when you look at the world particularly
a medieval world it's kind of persuasive
you know what kind of good God would
create that kind of crap you know what
kind of good God sits around saying mmm
leprosy good idea let's give them
leprosy mm so so the Lord of Light so
yeah all the religions are based this is
my general philosophy I think for
fantasy is not you know base it in
reality but then get a little
imaginative to it and rework the
elements and put this with that and add
your own your own touch to it and but
the grounding in in reality I think
gives it a certain verisimilitude and
plausibility we're just entirely made up
religions that are unconnected to
anything it's it's much more difficult
to make them plausible